in the video. Like one thing I'll say
about Tate is like he's he's spreading
he's making mistakes about Muslims very
publicly frequently like three times now
where he says that the attacker was
Muslim. No he wasn't like no he wasn't
I am a rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from fud to is
if you want to support someone like me
in learning salah then sponsor 10 people
for just 100 this Ramadan. Remember the
prophet peace be upon him said charity
does not decrease wealth. Click the
button and donate
[Music]
now. Brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in. I'm
going to be reacting to a video from
Sneak reacting to Andrew Tate. I'm here
with how you
how you doing? Okay.
So, everyone hope your Ramadan is going
good guys. Inshallah. Today, we are also
doing a live appeal on my channel where
we do reaction videos and at the same
time some reminders and also fundraising
for our salah plus project. Uh this year
we're aiming on teaching about 50,000
people how to pray salah. We have
onetoone instructors. We have we're
printing 50,000 guided prayer mats our
own inshallah in five different six six
different languages Italian, Spanish,
Portuguese, German and French and
Albanian inshallah bro sisters. You can
support that project. The link is there.
But let's get straight into it. So as
you know I done a video yesterday about
Andrew Tay and his perpetual cycle of
keep blaming Muslims. It's I find it so
strange. But we have the other opposite
as well which is Sneo which also but he
defends Muslims. But here's to what he
had to I don't know if you've seen it,
but let's react to it and let's see what
we can make out of it. In the video,
like one thing I'll say about Tate is
like he's he's spreading he's making
mistakes about Muslims very publicly
frequently like three times now where he
says that the attacker was Muslim. No,
he wasn't. Like no, he wasn't. And I
would like to see him correct himself on
that because it's just it's adding more
hate to Muslims when we already have so
much propaganda against us. you know,
simple fact checks like the guy, the
Pakistani guy in the UK, the invader guy
was Christian born, UK born. He wasn't
even an immigrant. He was born in the
UK. The other guy, the Christmas
attacker, that guy was tweeting at me
calling uh Mecca
Lucifer. And then this one, like the one
that had you talked about the PBD
podcast with the German guy, the German
guy was Christian. If you just go on his
Facebook, he's posting pictures in
church. It's like a white dude. His name
is Schwan Feinstein. His name is Schwein
is Bastian
Schweinsteiger. His name is Bastion
Schweinsteiger. And you're saying that
he's a Muslim terrorist? Like really?
That's the type of stuff I'm like, bro.
Like, do a little bit of research.
Please, please, because it's adding more
fuel to the fire. We have enough people
attacking us already. We don't need it
from one of our
own. That's no hate to take, bro. It's
just mistakes that that should be
corrected, especially when he's uh is
Googled that much. It's like it's not
helping us out, especially during the
month of Ramadan, bro. like we will this
is the time where we need good PR
everyone is trying to slander us like we
need to be united here for sure bro I
don't know what you make out of that but
to me you look at a person's language
you look at the body language with Sneo
he refers to himself he doesn't say I'm
Muslim I'm a Muslim like you know they
used to come and say we testify you're
the messenger of Allah we testify
and Allah said Allah knows his messenger
exactly it's like why do you need to
refer to that all the time
I know you're I know if you really
believe I'm you don't need to repeat me.
I know you're It's like the come and
keep saying yeah we know you're the
messenger of Allah. Why you keep
repeating it? Why do you find the need
to keep repeating it? One thing I see
with Andrew again I'm not trying to do
of him but he was like yeah I'm as a
Muslim man as a Muslim man. I'm a Muslim
man. Look he goes we already have hate
on us. He doesn't say I'm a Muslim. He's
already belonging. He said belong to us.
There's already hate on us. I picked up
on this little point because it tells me
I'll be honest with you, I've always
seen let's be honest at the end of the
day like we used to judge people based
on why stopped we judge from what's
apparent now and what we see from Sneo
is sincere. I'll be honest with you. I'm
so sorry. I've been with him. I mean
it's not everything I agree with he says
but I've been with him. I've ate with
him. I haven't traveled well I have
traveled with him to Bosnia once etc.
I've seen nothing but goodness. I've met
him once. He's a sincere brother in
speaks corner. is a sincere brother and
uh he and he he does da he defends look
look the fact that this bothers him like
it bothers us but it doesn't bother
Andrew T. What do you make out of it
like like seeing Sneak's behavior
compared to him giving Lia to Andrew
Tate? To be honest with you, look as
brother Sneo said in there,
a little bit of fact check. Yeah.
Will you come and then in a in a time
which is already bad for the Muslims,
you understand what I mean? You start
uh what was he? He's talking about Trump
that Trump is this, Trump is the other.
Trump who's trying to take our brothers
out of
Gaza and he has more is for Trump than
there Muslims. For the Muslims, you took
it from my mouth. More is to the people
who are against Islam than to Muslim.
Anyway, just his interviewee. Yeah. His
interviewer. Yeah. That pet. Yeah. Pet.
Yeah. Chihuahua. Pet Chihuahua.
him. He had more respect towards him
than he had
towards, you know, the Muslims. The
Muslims. Yes. And and the Muslims like
this, this is these are your brothers
and sisters, you know, and subh, I find
it very strange, but Sneo rightly called
Andrew Tate out. And I think this is
what we need to do cuz I'll be honest
with you, it's becoming more and more
apparent because he's made this mistake
three times. Sne even pointed out. And
it's not even I'm not going to call it a
mistake. It's not a mistake. He's doing
it on purpose. Look look uh Ali the the
German it was absolutely well known that
he wasn't a Muslim because because you
know sometimes they start with having uh
doubt they say oh a terrorist and then
they say oh no lone wolf mental health
yes but this one straight why did no one
said it's a terror attack no one said
it's a Muslim nothing it was from
someone did and did and did but from the
beginning oh he knew something the
German police didn't know. Exactly. And
and the fact it's not even a fact check
thing. It's not a mistake anymore. This
is intentional. It's intentional. He's
doing it. We we we want to find out why
is he keep doing this? Cuz I'll be
honest with you, the only thing that
comes to my mind is someone who's just I
mean this is the only thing that comes
to my mind and no one can blame me. I'm
so sorry. You the blame is on you.
You're putting a doubt on you. Yeah. And
I'm not going to come and assume the
best in you every single time because
now you're crossing all lines. To me it
just seems like somebody who's
pretending. You have to prove yourself.
Yeah. Yeah. We have the evidence of the
prophet when he was walking with his
wife and he went to the companions and
clarified messenger of Allah. We know he
said noan runs through the veins of
Adam. So I'm a human being and I'm
starting to have a question mark and
then I'm doubting you. I'm starting to
think you're a fake Muslim who's
pretending to be a Muslim. So you can
attack Muslims and get away by saying
I'm a Muslim. That's what I'm starting
to think of you. And no one can be
blamed to think of this. The racists
that say my friends are I got black
friends. Exactly. I'm not racist. I got
black friends. It's ridiculous. I mean
brothers and sisters, that's what we
need to say in I don't want to carry on.
It's Ramadan. I don't want to get into
too much thing but at the end of the day
he is somebody who is um crossing all
lines and I urge you guys inshallah to
stick on him in I and Allah will
inshallah expose the truth brothers and
sisters that's inshallah do not forget
to donate brothers and sisters £100 will
help teach 10 to 30 people to learn how
to pray salah to learn how to do wudoo
to learn to learn the movements of salah
inshallah you can be a part of this
amazing project till next time
my name is Joshua and I'm 19 years old
and I reverted to Islam 2 years ago
alhamdulillah Did you know if you teach
a revert like me how to pray salah, you
get the reward? Every single time I
pray, every time I wake up
for misha, you get the reward. But have
you ever thought about who teaches a
revert's children how to pray? The
reverts, of course, and you keep getting
the reward for generations. Donate now
and help 10 reverts. Learn salah for
just £100.
[Music]